pour son roman marie amorena voici
lentilles portrait chinois de félicie du
bois en félicite du bois bonsoir tu es
né en 1966 à âmes ont marre d'une mère
inconnue et 23 ans après tu fais un
roman de cette absence et ça s'appelle
maria morena le sujet c'est une quête
quête de sa mère dans le milieu de la
prostitution et on dirait que le
personnage de l'oea est complètement non
seulement attirer mais vraiment et parce
par ce milieu est complètement démonté
elle
dans ce niveau là comme dans une
obsession sans se poser de questions
sans savoir ce qui lui arrivait cette
évidence quelque chose qui s'impose à
elle et qui l'indiffère totalement les
inconnus que s'est constitué pour layrac
ont causé bien vous inventez c'est vrai
je pense et agit là dedans non j'ai
chauffé des conversations comme ça dans
les dents les cafés ouais mais c'est un
univers complètement les banques c'est
évident tu as passé ton enfance fatah
est élevé à notre-dame des oiseaux à
notre dame de sion
tu es tu été adopté par des gens jettent
à douter
par les gens dont je porte le voile
et qui monde qui m'ont donnés cette
éducation prestique mais chaleureuse
parce que j'en garde d'excellents c'est
vrai qu'ils étaient blancs aux yeux
bleus
ils sont trés ils sont bretons sont
d'origine bretonne et quand j'allais
passer mes vacances
en bretagne avec eux tous mes petits
cousins
rouge écarlate au soleil moi je le
donnais le noir et blanc tout de suite
et je comprenais pas encore déçu quand
ce n'était pas l'heure toujours j'ai
toujours su je ne me souviens pas d'une
date la qualif
a lancé ça je crois que c'est la plus
grande réussite de leurs 10 janvier sont
des gens bien passé comment été bonne
soeur moi je pars du principe que plus
on est brimé que l'on sait ce qu'on veut
et je pense que si j'avais pas eu une
éducation si strict
j'aurais pas été aussi évidemment sûr
d'être ce que je suis maintenant et avec
l'essai alors avec les filles c'est
c'est d'abord c'est des bandes bandes de
cire redoutable les banques de copies et
puis les ied d'essence dans un univers
féminin c'est vrai que ces troubles
c'est là bas que j'ai découvert les
plaisirs saphiques d'émail le livre oui
bah oui parce que quand on veut tous
quand on vient de les plantes etc autour
de soi on l'agglo fille veut maintenant
se préparer construire dans la glace
pour séduire l'envié de séduire les gens
qui sont autour de nous mais quand
autour de nous on n'a que des
professeurs parents et des jeunes filles
d'un forcément on est amené à séduire
mes camarades de classe et donc sa
façade est unique et après on découvre
autre chose
l'espace est détruit dans cette école
avant sur quoi ils avaient des on avait
des amitiés exclusive en fait c'était
surtout s'était jamais mariée voilà sont
des effleurements assis vraiment sondés
est clairement ce sont des et c'est un
peu des trucs quand même oui mais
gentil gens pour annick dans les enclos
l'écart oui c'est vrai que tu écris
l'âme
la première version du livre quand avait
vite ans c'était la balle passe
tellement là bas j'ai écrit ce livre
existe avant d'être révélée
j'ai écrit cette histoire douzaine de
fois jusqu'à tanger décide d'en faire un
roman et il avait envie qu'il soit édité
et c'est une historie ni sort que j'ai
toujours écrite évidente avec l'univers
de la prostitution qui était toujours en
toile de fond parce que quand j'étais
tout petit et que je pensais à ma mère
je me disais c'est soit une star alors
ça doit chanter moi j'avais mes et des
lettres ces enjeux les repérer dans les
suivent
soit une [ __ ] je vais je n'arrivais pas
dès le départ tu sais la fin je ne
pouvais pas m'imaginer que c'était une
mère ne
mr quad même c'est elle qui en ont la
plupart des gens moi c'était forcément
une star ou alors j'ai pas fait de
quartier et du bois il savait pas chez
ces bonnes soeurs tu as fait de très
bonnes études faut bien le dire tu as eu
ton bac à 16 ans maîtrise de droit
sciences politiques
et est-ce qu'après tu as connu les
expériences que tu racontes tu fais
arrivé à léa non pas du tout ça c'était
compagnon et en gt1
j'ai passé d'un jazz où j'ai fait mes
études ensuite je me suis à travailler
comme journaliste
entre guillemets parce que c'est pas
vraiment c'était plus un hasard qu'une
une vocation et ça c'est complètement
imaginaire passe et plus la littérature
et les films que j'ai vus contre chaude
non parce que quand elle fait des bonds
balle devient un moment elle rentre dans
le réseau de prostitution en colombie
dans les brochures hôtel et hôtel mais
c'est très naturellement que ça lui pose
pas de problème majeur sur le plan moral
elle va une part tout à fait ça comme
comme aller bosser dans une librairie ou
à la radio koi un an pourtant c'est bien
payé ouais c'était jamais tentée toi ça
n'a jamais tenté d'abord parce que j'ai
pas eu l'occasion
et en plus parce que j'avais d'autres
moyens
et ma vie et après tout pourquoi pas
elle n'a pas d'autre moyen haut niveau
comme ça et en fait ce qu'il faut pas me
dire pourquoi être trop cynique dommage
c'est que elle al'impression l intime
conviction de suivre les traces de
tonnerre
et donc elle se construit une question
ma mère aurait tué 40 mille personnes
que j'avais fait la même chose
l'homosexualité féminine non
donc vous ne se sent pas plus
homosexuels que non elle aime les femmes
peuvent pas spécialement nantes
mais est ce qu'elle se prostitue
seulement pour retrouver sa mère pour
autres les amériques parce que je pense
que quand on a je pense que quand on a
un problème d'identité c'est intimement
liés à la sexualité
on ne peut pas avoir une sexualité
normal et vignes
j'aime pas ta lensois
et quand on sait pas qui on l'aide parce
que c'est facile de dire branche une
fille je suis un garçon très bien mais
il faut que ça doit se vivre en rapport
avec les gens par rapport aux rapports
de séduction qu'on a elle sait
absolument pas qu'ils allaient ne se
sent pas plus filles que garçons ne sont
pas plus homo ou hétéro à sait pas qui
elle est alors on bâtit j'ai un livre
autobiographique même si tout n'est pas
vrai 1 me dire tu veux qu'on fasse un
petit portrait chinois là c'est quoi
c'est un défaut par exemple j'étais un
défaut - attendant une injure et
revêtement par toi
j'ai été un assassin j'étais un enfant
mais l'esprit est pourquoi ce qu'il est
intelligent
c'était un accident un accident dans une
porsche spyder sur la route de sa liste
une cicatrice
une cicatrice comme si lui versant c'est
une perversion perversion
azo fine ya que moi qui parle réseau
vieillit d'habitude donc voilà j'aime
tellement les animaux que abord
recherche d'éviter de témoigner parle de
ce genre de ballons mais j'ai trouvé mon
maître pas là mais quel animal du préfet
rech
les schaffhousois gros le seul fils en
effet la haye le petit jaguar
à bord d'irene plus beau essayer
j'espère mais si j'étais vraiment une
perversion pensées secrètes elle l'a
balancé pour la jeu